all right chapman dodge chrysler jeep
ram the sponsors of this segment is
doing something special for first
responders so of course president of
nevada operations don hamrick at chapman
automotive is back to give us the
details how you doing i'm great rocky
how are you oh i'm doing well it's been
50 years over 50 years chapman has been
given to our community over 50 years
we've been a part of this community we
just love las vegas um
you know the history goes deep yeah and
we're a family-owned
community dealership and that's why we
get involved in so many different
community events and organizations and
like to support what we're doing now
is we're going to do free registration
for all our first responders that's
amazing you know personally i don't
think we can do enough yeah for our
police department our fire department
those people who
every day
put their lives in danger for our
community
and
it's a small gesture but it's a
heartfelt gesture from chapman
automotive group so any of those people
who decide to buy a vehicle from us
their registration for the first year is
going to be on us that's amazing thank
you john for doing that for our
community yeah and you know there's only
one location of this particular
dealership now tell everybody where it
is and you know what kind of services
and products you guys have so right now
there is just our location on boulder
highway and sahara we like exclusivity
yes it's a free exclusive 3470 boulder
highway that's where chapman dodge
chrysler jeep and ram is located in the
near future and when i'm talking near
future i mean like
january okay we are going to have an
exclusive jeep store they're showing our
our dodge chrysler jeep ram store right
now but in january of this year of next
year we will have a brand new store open
and that will exclusively be jeep and
then dodge chrysler ram will be at this
other location but for right now this is
where you want to come if you're one of
our first responders and have special
care taking care of you amazing and this
particular dealership you guys have been
number one for what is it three years
running three years running what is the
key to that success really quick you
know i i we have great people and and
our employees just recognize how
important our relationships are with our
customers so we last year every month
chrysler surveys our customers to make
sure they're happy last month we were a
980 out of a thousand so they were not
perfect uh but we sold a lot of cars and
every once in awesome people you know
they give you a nine instead of a ten
you know and i understand
and sometimes we don't do as good as we
could so we're trying to get better but
our customers are happy our employees
are happy they love to come to work
every day i think that's a winning
combination yeah yeah well good job
thank you don we're proud of what you
guys bring to this community and you
check the reviews yeah the customers too
all right thank you so much for chapman
dodge chrysler jeep ram for sponsoring
this segment just call 702
457-1061 or visit las vegas dodge dot
com to learn more they have a special
offer for you chapman will pay the first
year's registration fees for any first
responder as don said don said in nevada
when they buy or lease a new vehicle so
las vegas now we'll be right back